the DC extended universe might be
struggling to find some critical success
but it's movies are still making a lot
of money and Warner Brothers has more
than a dozen sixteen actually for those
keeping count in various stages of
development right now so what a fans
have to look forward to over the next
five or so years let's crack the cover
and find out Wonder Woman
it's been a long road but director patty
Jenkins Wonder Woman movie is set to
finish a journey that many fans never
thought would arrive in theaters in June
2017
DC's biggest female hero is long overdue
for her solo shot at big-screen glory
thankfully the early trailers from the
film look fantastic and gal gadot take
on Diana was one of the best things
about Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
so there's something to build on but
there's been a cloud of negative buzz
surrounding the project with some
suppose at insiders claiming it's a mess
for the sake of DC and Wonder Woman fans
everywhere we hope those rumors are far
from the truth Justice League Zack
Snyder's Justice League set to hit
theaters in November 2017 picks up in
the wake of Batman vs Superman and is
reportedly having its tone heavily
retooled on the fly after all the
negative buzz from Batman vs Superman
overly grim tone it'll apparently follow
Batman and Wonder Woman as they look to
assemble a team of heroes to pick up the
slack following Superman's apparent
death at the end of that film
considering it's not the Justice League
without Superman we think it'll also
feature that guy's resurrection to
Aquaman he's been the butt of jokes for
years but James wons December 2018
Aquaman film looks to finally bring some
respect to the man who talks to fish
casting burly Game of Thrones alum Jason
Momoa and the title role didn't hurt
much either the film will reportedly
feature the classic comic character
Black Manta is the central villain and
introduced audiences at large to the
wider world of Atlantis and the undersea
kingdoms culture it's a risky venture
but having Furious 7 director James Wan
at the helm means if nothing else the
action should at least be up to snuff
Shazam
Warner Brothers has been prepping as
Shazam movie for a while now and all we
really know is that Dwayne the rock
Johnson is attached to play the villain
Black Adam outside of that there really
hasn't been a lot of momentum we don't
know a lot about
story and the filmmakers have been coy
about just how much it will or won't
connect to the DC EU at large
outside of Johnson when a projected
release date of April 2019 there's been
no word on casting like who will play
teenager Billy Batson or his
super-powered alter-ego whoever it is
the pressure will be on to actually
match up against Johnson as the big bad
Green Lantern Corps no casting has been
announced for this film about
super-powered space cops but the studio
is actively working this one behind the
scenes with a script from David Goyer
and Justin Rhodes on the way despite the
fact that it's three years out Warner
Brothers is bullish with a release date
of July 2020 already locked no word on
the plot but it's been described as
lethal weapon in space which you know
sounds pretty much perfect we also know
it'll focus on two different characters
the popular Green Lantern characters Hal
Jordan who was previously played by Ryan
Reynolds and Jon Stewart bringing Stuart
is a wise move he's a fan favorite and
getting him in the mix will help this
film stand out from the previous
critically panned Green Lantern flame
hey it really can't be worse right yeah
that part about the flash pretty much
the only thing we know about DC's flash
feature set for 2020 is that it'll star
as REM Miller as the big screen Barry
Allen aside from that everything's in
flux director rick fama Uwe was
originally attached but he left the
project at late 2016 due to creative
differences
it's been months and as of the making of
this video the studio is still looking
to fill the directional void considering
all the creative problems DC has had
behind the scenes the split from fama
Uwe isn't a great sign but Warner
Brothers looks to be taking its time to
try to get this one right which is smart
as the CW's hit flash series has proven
there's an audience out there that loves
this character the pressure is on to get
them out from in front of their TVs and
into theaters cyborg by the time cyborg
shows up in his solo movie fans should
be pretty familiar with him ray
Fischer's version of the character will
have co-starring roles in Justice League
in the flash and as much as Warner
Brothers loves cameos it wouldn't be
surprising to see him pop up elsewhere -
we already got a fleeting glimpse of
cyborg thanks
those handy Lex Luthor YouTube videos in
Batman vs Superman but will presumably
learn more about him over the next few
films since the character will have been
thoroughly introduced by the time this
one rolls around it stands to reason it
probably won't be an origin story or if
it is at least it won't be the entire
focus of the story the Batman Batman is
easily the cash cow of the DC Universe
and Warner Brothers seems keen to get a
standalone movie made starring Ben
Affleck as the new version of The Dark
Knight Affleck has been developing the
project for a while but it was recently
announced he wouldn't be directing
instead he'll be focusing on his work in
front of a camera
by moving Affleck out of the director's
chair and hiring Matt Reeves
it seems the studio might be trying to
get the project made sooner than later
meanwhile Affleck has said numerous
times that he wasn't in a huge hurry to
get it done little is known about the
project aside from the fact that it will
likely feature Joe Manganiello as key
villain Deathstroke but with the project
getting a revamp
who knows if Deathstroke will even
survive the rewrites dark universe
sometimes known as Justice League dark
during development this project is set
to focus on the mystical side of the DC
EU featuring characters such as John
Constantine Swamp Thing Deadman and
Zatanna edge of tomorrow's doug liman
signed on to direct in 2016
though there hasn't been much
information since then considering the
success Marvel had the Doctor Strange it
stands to reason Warner Brothers will be
keen to get this one off the bench soon
hopefully they'll tap Matt Ryan to play
John Constantine on the big screen
because let's be honest but dude is
perfect gotham city sirens David Ayer's
follow-up The Suicide Squad looks to be
this Harley Quinn centric spinoff as
opposed to a straight-up sequel air is
set to reteam with Margot Robbie for the
film which will focus on Harley Quinn
and several other female heroes and
villains across the DC Comics Canon no
word on which characters will show up
though ladies like Catwoman poison ivy
seem likely between this in the Wonder
Woman movie DC has an excellent
opportunity to take the edge over Marvel
Studios and female lead superhero fare
which can be a huge move for a studio
play
catchup the movies just you know need to
be good Justice League to Warner
Brothers originally penciled this one
for 2019 but it's since been thumped to
an unspecified date to clear out some
space for the Batman this one might not
be locked in anywhere at the moment but
of all the projects at the far end of
DC's master plan it stands to reason
another Justice League is one of the
most bankable the Avengers has become a
flagship franchise for Marvel and DC is
looking to leverage Justice League in
the same way of course there are a lot
of standalone movies and spin-offs to
make in the meantime Man of Steel 2 all
logic points the Superman featuring in
the Justice League film in some way but
despite Man of Steel formerly kicking
off this shared cinematic universe the
studio doesn't seem to be in a major
hurry to give him another solo adventure
the cast is confirmed a script in the
works but with so many other movies on
the docket you would have to think it
could be years until they actually get
around to making this one there's also
the questions of how DC wants to treat
the character in the long term and
whether or not they've learned anything
from the Hulk over at Marvel both are
insanely powerful characters and both
typically work a bit better in an
ensemble much like Marvel puts Hulk out
to play in the big movies DC could
follow the same playbook with Superman
Suicide Squad - a proper Suicide Squad
sequel is in development but there's
been no word on when it will actually
hit the big screen despite anemic
reviews the first film still made a
whole lot of money and introduced
characters like Margot Robbie's Harley
Quinn and Will Smith's Deadshot both of
whom will almost certainly pop up and
DCE you down the line Suicide Squad is a
semi proven commodity within the
universe which is significant but with
Warner Brothers high on getting gotham
city sirens off the ground
this one could stay on the backburner
for a while Deadshot Will Smith is one
of Hollywood's biggest stars so it's no
surprise Warner Brothers is looking to
spin him off with a film focused on his
Suicide Squad character Deadshot outside
of Ben Affleck Smith is arguably the
biggest star in the DC EU so it's only a
matter of time until they get him suited
back up for another fight against Batman
at this point the project seems to be in
very
early development and there's no word on
where it might eventually fit in the
overall schedule Black Adam this one has
everyone a bit confused Dwayne the rock
Johnson has been attached to co-star in
the Shazam movie for years playing the
villain Black Adam and we recently heard
that Warner Brothers is now developing a
full-fledged Black Adam spin-off them
which will split the character off into
more of an antihero Johnson explained
the plans to reporters we're building
our world that way and then we can come
together at some point it remains to be
seen how DC will juggle a two-prong side
section of the DC EU while they're still
trying to establish the main universe
Lobo word leaked in 2016 that Warner
Brothers is looking to bring the space
bounty-hunter Lobo back to the DC EU and
Wonder Woman writer Jason Fuchs is
reportedly working on the script now the
studio has also signed Brad Payton who
helmed the earthquake movie san andreas
to direct a film based on Lobo has hick
two-round development hell for the
better part of a decade with Sherlock
Holmes Guy Ritchie attached to make one
as far back as 2009 despite the false
starts this new project is apparently a
fresh take on the character considering
the success Fox and Marvel had with
Deadpool Lobo could be a foul-mouthed
sweet spot for DC to get in on the
action maybe thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]